[Music]
recently
a tourist who stole something from pom
pom a taurus
a tortoise like tortoise
so she's a canadian woman identified
only as
nicole what does she do
so she returned two mosaic tiles
and parts and parts of an amorpha
which is a like you know those like
vases
or mosses oh yeah they're like pointy
but they're like they're out and then
they have like two little thingies oh
yeah
the hercules vases yeah yeah exactly
what's up amorphous dude
so um and a piece of ceramics
and so she said that she stole these
items or like
she just took them because she wanted to
have a piece of history that no one else
still stole it
she stole it yeah but wait if you know
my reasoning you know that it's
justified
no what the [ __ ] it's like i wanted
something special
don't you understand so she said that
she she took it while on a trip
to pompeii in her early 20s she's now 36
years old and she said that
for the last 15 years she has had
crazy bad luck yes karma [ __ ] i love it
she revealed that she came back she had
suffered breast cancer
twice wow on other titties
breast cancer on her butt oh that's how
bad the lug was
she said that the last time ending in a
double mastectomy so she has no titties
yeah and then also that her family has
struggled with financial problems
she said we're good people and i don't
want to pass this curse on to my family
or children you ain't good you're not
good you trash an artifact [ __ ] and and
she must have been stealing for a minute
because no one that just steals for the
first time takes something
that important and valuable yeah you
know what i mean let me just take this
old fresco from this church because i
want it on my wall
yeah i know so she was telling the
because she ended up sending it
yeah thieving [ __ ] to the travel agency
that i
apparently she must have used but she
sent it to the travel agency and said
please take them
back uh they bring bad luck they had so
much negative energy
linked to that land of destruction
doesn't she know it costs money to bring
that [ __ ] back to
she should give them some money so
someone why don't you just throw it in
the ocean
uh-oh we gotta bring it back so she's
only returning it for her own
good too still selfish if yeah yeah why
don't you hold on to the bad luck so no
one else has to deal with it that should
be your punishment for stealing
i know yeah but she's like i've had
enough punishment hey
is the place with that volcanic eruption
yeah it's mount vesuvius
did you see that some guy um died
jacking off in 79 a.d
oh i heard that wasn't true though oh
the pompe jacket it's a great way to go
out
i mean if he busted right oh imagine
people
he died like this oh yeah he's frozen
and
and he's like oh i know didn't david uh
what's his face so no i'm not not davis
so
uh i can't kill him goliath oh the guy
killed bill he like
died with the doing that carradine
yeah he was jacking off he was jacking
off all the hit yeah that's like a
that's how he died yeah that's like a
huge fetish does that feel good
maybe it's like when people get choked
when they [ __ ] oh
no but he was doing it to himself so he
was choking himself out robin williams
was in a movie where his son
died that way what movie was that i
don't remember but
i remember that and then assad okay
anyway
back to this so so uh in that package it
also included a second letter
of confession from a canadian couple
who admitted to stealing stones back in
2005 and they said
we took them without thinking of the
pain and suffering these poor souls
experienced during the eruption of
vesuvius and their terrible death we are
sorry please forgive us for making this
terrible choice may their souls rest in
peace
that's why you can't take from hawaii
either you can't take those lava rocks
yeah
thanks for voting peter gonna [ __ ] you
up i learned that from the brady bunch
movie
oh yeah they said don't take their lava
rocks they got bad luck or something i
don't remember them
do you guys believe in this like
spiritual superstition stuff i don't
i believe if enough people like believed
it and they put the pretty projected the
energy onto it then i'm then i'm like
it's
yeah but you have bad energy to it i got
the [ __ ] nestle pure life holy
water and i [ __ ] cleaned that [ __ ]
[ __ ] it is pure life i don't i don't
believe in any of it
except for the hawaiian one i don't know
why it just feels like there's a lot of
cause you like hawaii that's why
i want to respect i don't take nothing
from there i'm like you leave it just
as beautiful as the way you are i
believe it all because i'm very
gullible and i'm just like well what
about those king tut people you know
like everyone that's ever taken anything
from king tut's whom like crazy things
happened to them
like they died and other crazy like if
they're on a set
of like the demon type poltergeist movie
oh yeah
that's so funny do you believe in it
well it only reminds me of this time
where well i think like people ten
it's it's people are very what's going
on are you people are very [ __ ]
fickle
i'm imitating you right now people are
very people are very fickle with their
[ __ ] right i remember this uh
oh it's good i remember this one time
when uh so i had a homie
where he was hardcore atheist right like
doesn't believe in
anything at all but it's not agnostic
it's atheists right it doesn't believe
in any type of yeah atheist you don't
believe in it i believe in science
that's atheist
this [ __ ] though would you [ __ ]
on anybody who believed in any type of
superstitions religion whatever right
just hyper aggressive with it so this
dude knocks up a girl i've never this
[ __ ] in the middle of school
gets on his knees it just starts
spreading
i never laughed so hard at somebody he
started praying i was like
who you brain do [ __ ] like who you
brain dude you were literally just
trashing everybody about this stuff i
think that happens it's like when
something bad happens to somebody they
want to believe in something higher
that'll fix them
right i always pray and become christian
when i have stomach pains
you're in the [ __ ] toilet like oh
jesus i'll go back to church
oh my jesus buddha anybody medusa
somebody i'm gonna do something
deuce i don't give a [ __ ] why does that
happen every time somebody gets sick
you're in bed you got the chills
oh i will go back to church god damn get
these boils off of my body
i feel like god damn [ __ ] drunk and
[ __ ] please where is a pompei located
italy italy they had a volcano man i've
been there and everybody died yeah 2
000 people died when the volcano erupted
in 79 a.d
and they stayed there up until the 16th
century
when it was rediscovered and yeah and
like they were just frozen in lava
basically a whole bunch of artifacts
it's pretty crazy because they even have
these murals that is pretty much
porn corn on these murals that's awesome
yeah that's why that guy was jacking up
orgies and stuff yeah like they had like
these like orgy rooms and then also
seeing their their bat their what is it
bath house
yeah bath houses as long as there's no
kids in those porn scenes i'm like cool
uh yeah i don't think there were yeah
and then just seeing like where they
actually slept and like
it's a pretty big place where i'm like
whoa this is crazy
have you guys seen that show uh lucifer
no no is it good
i've seen it on netflix it's like i
think it was like a cw show or something
so it was kind of whatever
how can you watch that as a christian
but i don't know man let me tell you
this though
so the concept of the show is very
interesting so it's about
lucifer who is satan right yeah so we
have this perception of what satan is
satan was a
fallen angel a fallen angel and he
battled god and he was sent to hell
so satan gets tired of being in hell and
he goes to earth so he's just living his
life he's [ __ ] [ __ ] doing whatever
the [ __ ] he wants right
and you start to understand his
perspective of how he thinks that god is
wrong and he's right
so when he he has this conversation a
very interesting conversation with
somebody where he's like
he shows him his satan face and the guy
freaks out and he's like getting sick of
how this guy's treating he's like wait
hold on a second
he goes i'm not the one at fault here
you go to hell because of what you do
i just run the spot he goes i'm the guy
that just
carries out your punishment i don't do
anything to make you come here
but then for all of eternity people have
blamed me for their sins when you're
terrible human beings you murder these
people he's the one that entices
people he's like what he's saying he
doesn't he just he was just sent to hell
he doesn't do anything else besides he's
an executive producer
so he's just existed before he went
there yeah so he was like hell has been
here i'm i
i was sent here to run it you guys come
here for your oh
i know demons and so now so he's like
the king of demons
so in in hell only an a an angel
can or a deity from heaven can be in
charge of hell so if it's not him it has
to be another angel
so he was sent down there to control
that so that because he's a fallen angel
i know you should watch the good place i
really like it the good place was good
up until
the third season it got a little
ridiculous yeah i like the fourth season
too
well the good place is also another
another you trash no but another good
thing about
it the good place with the very
interesting thing about that especially
in the four seasons they talk about the
afterlife
yeah and how if you live in an attorney
internal happiness and you don't have an
end goal and you just have to listen
you're just a zombie yeah what's the
worst there's no purpose can you make
rice krispies treats out there make
anything you want
anything whatever you want i'm down
i have to have a lot of hobbies i think
i could do okay in heaven you
kind of remind me of uh tahani because
she's just like her entire thing is like
oh i'll leave heaven once i accomplish
my entire life oh yeah
i think i'd be bored after 423 years
though why they're very specific
yeah because there was people that was
the concept uh towards that fourth
season was there's people who've been
there for thousands of years
they're like on board mastered and done
everything that they want and so they're
walking
and they're actually miserable because
they have nothing else to do so heaven's
miserable for them yeah what an
interesting concept
they do solve that problem but you gotta
watch the show well that actually when
things are accomplished
easily it's boring yeah they're you need
some kind of resistance you know channel
after school
they do they did a video on it like um
about how we don't actually want
everything to be easy and given to us
because and they did this like a study
on rome and how like
rome was like this huge empire and
everybody was like having crazy parties
and like
sex parties and stuff but then they just
like had everything they had like
fruit and feasts and girls and sex all
things
um that they got bored and so they would
just they started going evil because
there's like nothing left to do
you talk about the us or what the [ __ ]
are you talking i mean like once there's
too much to do
they people start going evil and they
get only they only get pleasure out of
pain
or bringing other people pain so they
would ship in slave girls from the
uh country over and they'd have this big
party and they'd be like the centerpiece
of the parade
and they'd wear flower crowns and they'd
be all beautiful and then
at the end of the parade they would tie
them to a stake and release a bunch of
tigers on them and like
everybody would watch them get devoured
by tigers and lions oh my god
is that what they did at the coliseum
and that's why sparta kissing should be
like i'm gonna kill you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
maybe remember that one i would love
reality be great mythology though i want
multiple gods like that that should be
oh you love greek
oh i love that [ __ ] you have a favorite
god
me it would definitely have to either be
poseidon
i'm thinking the god of war not cupid
poseidon's kids came out of his [ __ ]
head though that's
weird is that no i don't think so you're
not talking about zeus
because it is poseidon is the king of
the waters yeah yeah yeah yeah i would
want to be poseidon i want to be either
the god of war
who's the goat guy half goat half man i
think that's cool i think that's god of
war
is a bull he has a bull oh the militar
is a bull i wasn't no the guy that plays
the [ __ ] mandolin and he's got a
goat in it danny devito played yeah in
the hercules
yeah she's tired she's a clown should be
making people [ __ ] go [ __ ]
go [ __ ] go [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you